good to see you both congratulations on
the film vanessa congratulations on your
feature film debut did the experience
surpass your expectations
uh well i didn't have expectations like
i always like to have expectations
before something so i'll kind of know
like what is going to happen but i
didn't have any expectations and so i
think that was very helpful because
anything probably could have surpassed
them but
i think even if i did they they
definitely did i just never wanted to go
home or leave
or at least so yes yeah yes
it did look like quite the party uh
dakota you know with yourself here
vanessa cooper leslie this entire
amazing cast who among you all you think
is like the best party starter like who
would be the realest party starter in
that group
probably cooper
yeah you think cooper
well i'm thinking of the people who it's
not so yes i think that would leave
cooper
yeah
this film takes such a um
such a mature approach to the idea of
how complicated love and relationships
can be and the question is posed about
soul mates do the both of you believe in
soul mates
i think i believe in soul mates really i
think so i'm
i'm undecided a lot of the time but i
think there are people for people i just
don't believe it's like as easy as
calling it a soul mate but i do think it
makes you feel better to call it a soul
mate
yeah it feels more like dramatic and
and call it
yeah and concrete dakota do you think
that i like that idea that there are
people for people is that something that
you kind of subscribe to as well
yeah i think there's your people and
then there's other people's people
and
i like to believe in soul mates because
it's romantic
i'm a romantic person
what was it like
getting to know each other how did you
guys develop your bond as a mother and
daughter in this
we
just
started talking on set and
um
really i really like vanessa i really
like her mind and her heart and i like
to hear what she has to think about
things and
um i really want her to be happy and
feel good and
um
she's so talented in so many departments
and i don't know i think we just get
along
and i like working with you
it was fun
what do you think
well no one has really ever like wanted
to hear what i have to think about
things so like when that started
happening i felt so much more
comfortable and so much
freer like like i could
just do what whatever i wanted and then
when you feel comfortable with someone
then you don't have to pretend
it's a real bummer because
she has the most wonderful thoughts
so
i wish more people would
want to know what you think of things
i think it's such a lovely uh way to get
to know each other and you guys come
across so
um
[Music]
with such a strong relationship in the
film uh finally dakota how excited are
you looking forward to working with
sydney sweeney in uh in her upcoming
marvel universe madame webb
i'm so excited i really like her i like
her work
i met her recently and she's so lovely
and
sweet and i like working with nice
people talented people so i think i
think it'll be good
awesome well congratulations again both
of you on this film thank you so much
for taking the time all the best thank
you